posez les banderoles les slogans et opté
cette fois ci pour une expression de
leur colère en musique et en chant avec
toute sorte d'instrument
il est 15 heures une délégation est
reçue par une mission d'inspection
générale diligentée par le ministère
nous voulons montrer que nous refusons
ce nouveau système de retraites et que
nous souhaitons conserver le système de
retraite
par les partitions tout en l'améliorant
ensuite faire remonter un certain nombre
de nos revendications à savoir non pas
une suspension des suppressions de
postes mais un moratoire
c'est à dire 'ok durant un certain
nombre d'années que la question des
suppressions ne se pose plus ensuite le
report des oc 3 sûr qu'on semble avoir
obtenu aujourd'hui la détermination ne
faiblit pas au contraire elle est
volontairement bruyante comme ont
suggéré les syndicats des zones
d'animation en attendant
l'intersyndicale
le mouvement est soutenu par les
enseignants du premier degré certains se
sont déplacés avec leurs enfants
nous sommes aussi mobilisée au premier
degré peut-être plus difficilement que
le secondaire mais la première grille
aussi mobilisé d'autant plus cet effort
nous impacte davantage parce que nous ne
bénéficions pas des primes
nous sommes au premier degré vous ne
bénéficiez pas de rim par conséquent
lorsque la retraite
la réforme a passé eh bien nous serons
doublement impacté mois entre femmes et
en plus en tant que enseignants du
premier degré vous avez des contraintes
parce que c'est le premier degré comment
est ce que vous pouvez manifester votre
mécontentement
en effet selon le syndicat appelle à
faire grève dans ça je le fais je fais
une déclaration 48 heures à l'avancé
afin qu'on puisse organiser un service
minimum s'il ya lieu de le faire
maintenant
aujourd'hui c'est hors temps scolaire
dont je me déplace comme je le dis
souvent je le fais en mon âme et
conscience
à l'issue de trois heures de rencontre
aucune réponse concrète n'a été apportée
déception donc pour une intersyndicale
qui a donné rendez vous au corps
enseignant pour une journée
interprofessionnelle pour une nouvelle
journée de mobilisation demain dès 9
heures